a couple weeks ago you tweeted something
out then yeah i'm gonna bring it up okay
that got a
crazy amount of attention
which
did it sports illustrated swimsuit
edition i believe you're referring to
yes
i tweeted out sorry
not beautiful
yeah people were very happy with that
and then everyone got upset yes they did
and then i left twitter again more or
less right after that and everyone
assumed that that was why and it
actually it wasn't
now
it was it was i suppose in some sense it
was because what happened was an
indication of
the problem with twitter but i had been
not reading twitter comments for about
three weeks although i had been
tweeting through an intermediary one of
my staff members so i'd email him a
tweet but not reading comments because i
found that quite um irksome yeah you're
associating with the
devil
sure yeah exactly that was like sort of
like standing in a public park where
anybody no matter who they were could
come up and yell at you
to any size audience about anything they
wanted day or night
and so
i've been thinking that through i'm
going to write an article about what's
wrong with twitter and social media in
general but
no i looked at the sports illustrated
cover
and they had a
a
rather
overweight
young woman quite symmetrical
so nice facial features and so forth
with a very revealing swimsuit on the
cover
and i thought
no
like not not in a personal way but
it's unbelievably manipulative for about
three different reasons the first is
it's a very tawdry attempt to capitalize
on cheap sales
that's and i mean cheap in a specific
way sports illustrated hit the gold mine
with their swimsuit cover i suppose 20
years ago whenever they established that
because it was obviously it's a sports
magazine so it's about athletics it's
about athletic people it's about that
athletic bodies and they had a swimsuit
issue and it really was a big hit and
then it became kind of a cultural icon
and it's a very specific kind of
cultural icon because it
focuses on a very exceptional kind of
high-end beauty
and so that beauty would involve
symmetry and signals of youth because
that's part of
beauty sexual beauty
physical beauty
waist to hip ratio for women but with
sports illustrated it's also
highlighting a kind of athleticism in
body type
and that's a very specific form of
beauty you have to be young you have to
be female generally you have to be
extremely athletic you have to be
shapely in a very particular way and
that would be with the waist-to-hip
ratio of 0.68 because that's what's been
established cross-culturally as ideal
from the perspective of male uh
sexual interest let's say but that's
also associated with fertility
and so it's a marker that has a
biological basis and so
even if you're a very beautiful woman
you're you're hard-pressed to be
beautiful enough to be on the cover of
sports illustrated for the swimsuit
issue and so it's a very it's a pinnacle
achievement of sorts and it's focused on
a very idealized and specific form of
beauty and that's obviously exclusionary
it's obviously exclusionary it excludes
everyone right and and it does that to
highlight a kind of ideal and that's
a particular idea of beauty and there
are some cultural boundaries around that
so you could say well it's a westernized
form of beauty it's like yeah and you
can point to reuben's paintings of
more plump women and say well there's an
exception it's like great you think
you're a genius for finding that
exception good for you you know the
reuben's painting like more power to you
but that doesn't mean anything at all
about the universality of images of
beauty and
so the cover bothered me a lot because
it was a cheap manipulation of something
that had been working very well for
sports illustrated it was also an
insistence that all of a sudden this
non-athletic body type
is
as beautiful as the standard
swimsuit
model for sports illustrated and
it's not it's not as athletic and it's
not as healthy and that's that and it's
also not arbitrary and so the whole
thing is a lie and then it's a lie
that's a manipulation of that young
woman
now she partakes in that because she
participates in it but it's still
they're not on her side they're
exploiting her as far as i'm concerned
and she may be participating in that
exploitation but they're still
exploiting her so don't pull any moral
stunts on me because you're irritated
about my opinion about the sports
illustrated cover when it's bloody clear
to anybody with eyes that that was
manipulative in 20 different ways
and so and i'm also not willing to
sacrifice
these
ideals
for inclusiveness it's like no not
everyone's a genius
no not everyone's picasso
no not everyone's young and healthy and
no
not everyone is a sports illustrated
swimsuit model period and [__] you if
you don't like it
so that's basically
what i thought about that i certainly
didn't think it would cause as much
trouble as it did you know when people
were on my case for being mean it's like
yeah i know i'm always mean because
you know that's
well also like life is hard and like
life is mean right and it's hard for
people first first of all i have great
sympathy for anybody overweight because
of the health struggles i went through
and you lost a whole bunch of weight
it's not like being overweight is fun
right no that's a whole other problem to
get into with um i think people have
such an issue losing weight yeah that
society has said you know what it's fine
because because you've had so much
trouble it's that it's probably your
genetics so well there's
when i look at someone who's obese on
the street i think
oh that's too bad like that's too bad i
i don't think you know
obese pig eats too much has no
self-control i don't think that i think
uh bad mismatch between genetic
proclivity and
appalling diet and the appalling diet is
basically we're not going to get into
this but basically carbohydrate heavy
and sugar loaded and fair enough you
know we try to hard the whole world to
make calories cheap
and we did that we did that no one's
starving and great but now we have an
obesity problem and it's a major problem
and i'm not going to pretend that it's
okay it's not okay that doesn't mean i
don't have sympathy for it and i'm not
willing to sacrifice any ideals for this
idiot inclusiveness i'm done with that
and so should everyone else be and most
i think most people are
and they look at that cover and they
know it's manipulative and
and a lie in a deep sense